hello everyone
how are you great i want to uh thank uh
administrator guzman uh who's running
the show for us
and we're really starting to move here
and the vice president
thank you you're focused on small
business we're pushing uh
lenders to raise their game and provide
more help to the small
many small businesses you know
particularly hispanic as well as
african-american small businesses are
just out of business because they
got bypassed the first time around today
i'm proud to sign the extension which
i'll be doing a second
of the paycheck protection program it is
a bipartisan
accomplishment nearly 90 000 business
words are still in line
and there's money left without somebody
signing this bill today there are
hundreds of thousands of people who
could lose their jobs
and small family businesses that might
close forever
and as you know small business is the
backbone of our economy representing
almost 50 percent of all the employees
in america
and i want to thank senators carton
shaheen
rubio and collins for their work in the
senate his bipartisan effort
and young kim and velazquez
as well as luke meyer
for their work in the house to make sure
this happened
and the last two months we've improved
forgivable loans
for three thousand three three million
six hundred small businesses
six hundred thousand small businesses
and three million three hundred of those
small businesses
were less than higher had fewer than uh
20 employees
which is the backbone of most of the
communities so with that i'm going to
sign this and
thank you all for coming
thanks mr president
mr president mr president who should pay
for your infrastructure plan
mr president who should pay for the
infrastructure plan
thank you guys let's go thank you mr
president